I'm going to carry on now with our next presentation
for this budget workshop. And now we will shift to
gears to hear from the Mayor's office. And at this time, I would
like to welcome our Chief of staff for the Mayor's office, ms.
Marvelette Hunter and Valerie Barry,
to provide the Mayor's Office department budget presentation. I want
to thank you all for your presentation station and turn the floor to
you. Excellent. Good morning,
chair and council members and council representatives.
I am here today with our CFO, Valerie Berry, and Valerie
has ridden side chair with me for the last six
budget presentations, so really glad that she is here.
We also have several members of the Mayor's office executive team
who are present, and I would like for them to please stand and
be recognized right now.
Thank you all.
I may have a couple of them come forward during
our Q and A time period.
If you have any additional questions that relate to their specific
areas of expertise. After I finish the budget
this year, I'm excited to be able to be here with you in person
instead of virtually, which was our last fate.
We have certainly had our fair share of challenges through this
administration, but just like Houston, we've proven that
we are resilient and that we can come through anything, even a global
pandemic. I'd like to publicly thank the city of Houston
for their support of Mayor Turner and this administration.
And I also want to thank the 22,000 employees
who work tirelessly to serve the citizens
of Houston. Today. I'm pleased to present to
you the FY 23 Mayor's Office proposed budget.
And if we could have our first slide, please.
Here is the Functional organization chart summarizing our six
General fund divisions. First, we have
our executive offices, which includes our boards
and commissions, education,
constituent services, community relations and our council
relations. Next we have our Agenda office,
the Economic Development Office, government relations,
Communications and our Veteran Affairs Office.
You'll note here the total budget for each of the six divisions
as well as the number of FTEs for each of those respective
divisions. Next slide, please.
There are two special revenue funds administered
by the Mayor's office. First, we have our Cable
TV Special Fund, whose functional
organization chart you see before you with the budget and
the number of FTEs that are represented.
Next slide, please.
You'll see here the other special fund, which is
our Tourism and Promotion Special Fund.
And this organizational chart shows the budget and the
FTEs for each of those respective divisions.
The tourism and promotion fund includes our special events,
trade and international affairs, and it also includes cultural affairs.
Next slide, please.
The next four slides are going to share with
you our course services within the Mayor's office.
First we looked at divisions that are mandated by federal
or state statutes or municipal code. And then
we looked at divisions that were created to meet the needs of the citizens
of Houston. Now, although most of our divisions
are not statutorily required,
the citizens of Houston certainly depend on those services that we
provide on a daily basis.
So on this particular slide, you see our Office of Education,
our Boards and commissions and our Constituent Services divisions.
And I just wanted to note just a couple of highlights from each one of
those and the rest is there for your reading but heart
Houston youth. That is one of the Mayor's signature initiatives and that
is administered through our Education Office. And we
are on track currently this year to provide 12,000
jobs for our youth ages 16 to 24.
And I will make note that when that program first started, we were only providing
450 jobs. And now we have brought on the private
sector and all of the additional jobs now are private sector
related. I'll also note that
as far as our Boards and Commissions is concerned, we have,
and many people don't know this, over 160
Boards and Commissions, and that's a lot of people
that we have to administrate over. And then lastly, for Constituent
Services, just making a note that there are approximately 1400
pieces of correspondence that comes in to the Mayor's office on a monthly basis.
And with a very lean staff of two, we're able to move
that and be responsive to the citizens of Houston.
Next slide, please.
Here we have our agenda office, the Economic Development
office and the Special Events office. And all of
these are statutorily mandated.
I wanted to highlight a couple of things, and that is through our
Economic Development Office. This is our office that administers the
tours, the management districts, the tax abatements,
and is responsible for over $25 million
in billings through the Industrial Assessments
each year. And then I wanted to also make note of
our Special Events Office. Now that we are past COVID or
post COVID and beginning to return to our mini events,
this particular office produces about 2000
special events per year for the City of Houston.
Next slide, please.
Here we have our Intergovernmental Relations Office,
our Cultural Affairs, as well as our Veteran Affairs.
And I wanted to highlight that our Gr team
was mainly responsible for helping to bring $630,000,000
of ARPA funds, which is really being
relied upon to help us get through not only this year,
but the next two years of deficits that
we were experiencing due to COVID. So very important,
their work that they're doing. And then our Veteran Affairs.
I wanted to point out that Houston hosts the second largest veteran
population in the country, over 300,000
veterans, and this office basically provides services, referral services
to that population.
Next slide, please.
Lastly, we have our communications office and our
trade and international affairs and also Houston Television.
And I wanted to point out that, of course,
communications statutorily required by the Texas Public
Information Act. But I wanted to point out that we receive about 170
TPS per year and over 270 requests for
proclamations or letters from the Mayor's office.
And so that is a very busy office
with a staff of two in trade and international affairs.
This office is critical in coordinating the Mayor's
abroad trade missions and also in marketing
the City of Houston as an international city which
we're very proud of. And then, lastly,
Houston television. And that is
mandated by Chapter 37 of the City of Houston Code of
Ordinances. And of course the impact is
better transparency of government and making sure that
we have an informed public.
Next slide please.
This slide summarizes our revenues for the three
funds that are managed in the Mayor's office. We have our general
fund and we also have Houston television special revenue
fund and the tourism and promotion special revenue
fund. From our FY 22 estimate,
the General Fund has increased in revenues of approximately
$887,000 for FY
23 and this is primarily due to the projected revenue from
the new Digital Kiosk, which will begin generating
revenue in the fourth quarter of 22.
The revenue projected for FY 23 is for
a full year of those revenues and the revenue
projection for FY 22 was only prorated for a
May start date. So there's also a $33,000
increase in the Industrial District assessment
revenue due to the expected increase in
taxable values by 6.3 million.
For our Houston Television Fund, we are projecting
an overall revenue decrease of 69,000
over the FY 22 estimate and this is
primarily due to the projected decrease of the Peg fees, the public
education and governmental revenues. And this is something that I've been sharing
with Council for the last few years. That trend
is continuing. Finally, for our Tourism
and Promotion Fund, we are estimating an approximate $2.95
million increase in revenue from our FY
22 estimates and the increase is primarily due
to the projected post pandemic increase
in hotel Occupancy tax revenues,
which we're very excited about based on information that
has been provided by Houston. First, as you will recall, the FY
21 revenues took a substantial hit as
a result of COVID nineteen's impact and
so we are now projecting for FY
22 having a gradual comeback and for FY
23 revenue budget reflects a very
strong return to pre COVID activity.
Next slide please.
This slide reiterates the largest drivers of the revenue
increases and decreases for FY 23 and most of
which I discussed on the previous slide.
General Fund revenue from the Digital Kiosk contract,
HTV, the Peg, contributions from state franchise fees
and a chargeback to funds for HTV.
And lastly, tourism promotion. The hot receipts come
back to pre COVID levels.
Next slide please.
This slide captures the expenditure comparison for all
of our funds between the year in FY 22 estimate
and the FY 23 proposed budget. So the
General Fund shows an expenditure increase of
$230,000 or 2.9%.
However, this percentage includes the net adjustments
which I'll talk about a little bit later for contractual municipal hope,
pay increases, health insurance and restricted
accounts. The almost $2.1 million
increase in Houston Television Special Revenue Fund is primarily due
to the projection in capital projects from
year to year. So the FY 23 planned
capital project improvements include the upgrade for
the City Hall chambers, video control room,
which was much needed, the new build of the City Council
chambers and the terminal room along with the
few much smaller projects. So these funds
are capital dollars that are restricted for
capital use only, so they cannot be used for administrative purposes.
In the Tourism Special Revenue Fund, we project an increase of
$3.1 million in expenditures or
17.47% from the FY 22
budget. And this is primarily due to the increase in the
city's net receipts of the hot taxes and thus
the city's payment going out to the
arts partner houston Arts Alliance
is projected to increase. As noted
earlier, our FY 23 budget reflects a strong return
to precovid activity and therefore, again an
increase in the payment to the arts partner is anticipated.
Next slide please.
The next three slides provides a graphic representation of our
personnel versus non personnel budgeted expenses
for the Mayor's office's three funds.
So to elaborate on that, the Mayor's Office General fund is
65% personnel expenditures.
Of the remaining 35%,
68% of that is for the general fund transfer
to subsidize special events.
So the restricted accounts comprise 22% of this
portion, leaving only 10%
of the non personnel budget for services
and supplies and those things like the novice account,
office expenses, travel, parking and the like.
Next slide, please.
The Houston Television Special Revenue Fund is 26%
personnel expenditures. Of the remaining 74%,
more than half is for the planned capital improvement
and more than a third is for the contractual payment to
Houston Media Source. And this is the
city's public access channel partner. The services and
supplies account for only 6% and the
restricted accounts also take another 6% of
this portion.
Next slide, please.
Lastly, the tourism promotion special revenue fund
is 15% personnel expenditures and
85% other. And please keep in
mind that this is the fund where we receive our hot taxes. So therefore
the personnel budget is relatively very small.
92% of the other charges are to pay the
arts partner for the hot agreement and then supplies
and services are there for only about 7% of the
other for the entire fund.
Next slide please.
This slide gives a great summary of the
net change in expenditure budget from FY 22
to FY 23. The slide illustrates
the net increase of $230,000
from the FY 22 budget to FY 23
proposed budget. And this represents
a 2.9% change as
discussed on slide number eleven. So beginning
at the very top of this
chart, you'll see that the Mayor's office FY 22
operating budget is $6.95 million.
So once we add to that our restricted account budget of 621,000
FY 22 contractual municipal hope increases
of 3% of 140,000
revised projection of restricted accounts of 76,000
the FY 22 council surplus of
10,000, which was granted to us from council member
Cisanero's Office for an Intern, and the Mayor's Office
of Education and Funding for marketing specialists and
special events and program adjustments that we took
in the Economic Development Office for a
total FY 22 budget of $7.9 million.
Now, the next two areas, shaded areas on the chart,
the blocks include our proposed operating budget adjustments
for FY 23, and the first item
is the reverse of the one time funding from Council Member
Cisnero's office, the FY 22 surplus,
FY 21 surplus, and the balance of the
annualized funding amount for the economic development
programming. So, added to this are the contractual
adjustments for hope increases, health and benefits
offset by a reduction in the restricted
accounts taking. All of the increases
and the decreases from the FY 22 operating budget
yields the proposed FY 23 budget of
$8.16 million for the Mayor's
office. Next slide, please.
This slide provides a brief narrative of each fund's expenditure highlights
for your reference, and we discuss the expenditure highlights
that are listed on slide number eleven. The general
fund expense budget includes funding for contractual municipal hope
pay increases, health benefits and
restricted accounts. And some of the highlights of the fund include
funding for capital improvements through Houston Television
and in the Tourism Promotion Special Revenue Fund, the increase
being attributed to the increase in hotel
occupancy tax.
Next slide, please.
This concludes the financial portion of the Mayor's Office FY 23
budget presentation. For your reference, we have included our
office demographics and some just some
of our FY 22 accomplishments in the appendix section.
Thank you, and I'll be happy to answer any questions that you may have.
And we also have our executive staff here in chambers to assist
with questions that you may have regarding their specific areas of
focus. I know that we have Andy Icken here from economic development.
Why don't you all stand up everybody.
So thank you all so much again. So we do
have Ted Irving who is here, we have representatives from
Veteran Affairs and we have representatives from Special Events
as well as our Executive Offices. So turn
it over to you. Any questions that you may have, we're happy to answer.
Thank you very much, Ms. Hunter. And your staff is well represented.
Great to see everyone here in the chamber with you.
We also have been joined by a few colleagues and
staff members. Council member Sally Alcorn has joined us and has been
here this morning along with staff from council member
Tasha Jackson as well as council member Michael Kubosh's
office. So I wanted to acknowledge everyone here, we do have a couple of
our council members in the queue before we get to our public speakers,
but first, let's hear from Council Member Alcorn.
Thank you, Chair, and thank you ms. Hunter,
the big increases were in the HTV and then to
the arts. I think I submitted those in writing, but you've covered them here.
So I appreciate that. If we could have you or Mr.
Irving elaborate a little bit more on the capital improvements that
are being made. This include what's already been done in the chamber?
Is more stuff coming? What's going on in the control room?
A little bit more color around what I will allow
serving to provide a little bit more detail regarding
some of the improvements. But as you recall, we did a
lot of improvements here. The lighting, of course, the sound.
We still have some additional work to do. And those funds
that we have that are part of the budget are specifically for capital improvements only.
So you will see some additional work, but I'll allow him to elaborate further.
Good morning. Good morning.
To answer your question on the capital improvements, the city
council horseshoe area was a phase one.
And so the phase two is the control room that is behind
this space. And at one point in time,
that control room as well as the annex chambers control room had not
been updated. There have been no updates excuse me, since 1997.
They are extremely outdated. But due to the Cares
Act, the annex control room has been modernized
with virtual technology. In the next phase, the new build that
Chief Hunter is discussing that we are working to have started
here, hopefully in July, FY 23,
will be this control room to have it modernized.
Thank you, Council Member and Mr. Irving, I know having worked with you recently
on the technology, the TTI committee, we are still tweaking
some things. So, council Member, it is very much an ongoing
program with coordination with the speakers and the It
platforms and HTV, of course, trying to coordinate
it all. So we thank you for that ongoing effort. Next we'll hear
from Council member Cayman staff.
Thank you, chair. Thank you, Ms. Hunter. Ms. Hunter, I was curious if
you could speak to, given the city's budgetary constraints,
any unmet needs or really particularly
critical unmet needs that you all have identified.
Well, I don't think we have any critical unmet needs
at current. I think the biggest challenge that we face is
that over the last several years, we have trimmed our budgets
and kept everything very, very tight. And so in some instances,
we've actually had to eliminate vacancies.
And therefore our staffing is at a minimal
right now. So as we continue to respond to
citizens calls and all of the other things that we have to
do within the office, it does present a challenge. But as far
as unmet met needs, I don't think that we have any major ones
at this point. Thank you for that question.
We have a follow up question now in the queue from Council Member Alcorn.
Thank you, Chair. On the Kiosk revenue, how many kiosks does
that represent? Trying to remember. I think we have a contract
for 25, but I'm going to have Andy Icken to come forward and answer those
specific questions. Thank you.
Good morning, Mr. Ickin. Welcome to the chamber.
Good morning. Chief of staff is correct. The first
segment, if you remember, council passed the first 25.
We're well on the way to do that right now. They have been very well
received and the advertising revenue was exceeding the expectations that we had at
that time. I just saw one going in this morning as I was
coming in on Prairie and Fanon. So that'll be 25
within 75. 75 within
fiscal year 23. Yeah, we're doing about five a month right now.
That's the pace at which they are letting contracts and doing everything right
now. I wouldn't be surprised if they don't come back to us very
soon. If remember, we put a pause at 25.
All the feedback we're getting, I'm not sure if council has any direct feedback
has been very positive. Thank you.
It might be helpful, director and
chief, to see a map of all of that. I know
at some point to get that update would be very we have such a map
and we'll get that for you. Excellent. Very good. Well, I believe that is it
for comments from the Horseshoe.
Both council and staff have had their opportunity to speak. So we'll
turn to those in public comment with the
five virtual speakers that have signed up. We're seeing two
of whom are here online or perhaps three. And we're going
to start with Ms. Saba Blanding. Ms.
Blanding, we may 1 hear from you.
Good morning. Thank you for your time.
I had a couple of questions. The first was that on
slide two it says the executive office develops and coordinates
all city policies. Can we return to a budget hearings where
the public can ask department directors their questions directly? If not,
why not? And then my second question is on slide
28. You mentioned initiatives with Houston's unhoused community.
What efforts are being made to be proactive and mitigate evictions?
Our housing department is grossly underfunded with a budget of only $400,000.
Houston renters, I mean, to quote the Houston Chronicle,
houston renters are now more cost burdened and evicted at a higher rate than
renters in Dallas, Chicago or Atlanta.
In 2019, one in eleven renter households in Harris County had
an eviction notice posted on their door. I know Harris and Houston are
different, but we have a lot of overlap. And an analysis
by the eviction lab at Princeton University found 16 Houston apartment
complexes have filed for more than 100 evictions each and
over the course of the pandemic. So the first question is about thank you,
Ms. Landing, Ms. Blanding, thank you
for your question. Your time has expired. Give the chief
the option to respond. But I think we, as you understand, have been
restricted by the instruction of the administration
and seeing no council members in queue to respond,
we will move on to our next speaker, who is Ms.
Lien Chong. Ms. Chong, if you're with us,
we'll give you a moment to hit star six to unmute or
otherwise speak up and we'll hear you.
Hello, can you hear me? Yes, Ms. Chong. Go ahead.
We hear you and see you online. Yes, ma'am. Thank you.
Awesome. So I am an artist and
I'm an organizer for Arts Accountability Houston.
And we have many engaged artists who are
advocating for public funding for the arts here in
Houston. Now, we are aware of a proposal that's
been sent to the mayor by the Cultural District for
Arca funding to be allocated to the arts
in Houston. I'd like to sort of as a member of
the public Advocate for these fundings to
go to fund the arts here in
Houston. I know it's not on the budget, but we are
curious to know when these funds
will be confirmed from the city to support
the arts here in Houston. Any organizations
are still suffering as a result of the pandemic
and we would really like for the city to
allocate ARPA funding towards the arts here in
Houston. Thank you very much, Mrs. Chong. We're well
aware of the ongoing challenges for our arts community
and thank you very much for bringing this question to council. It is something
that we are working on with local organizations and
appreciate you calling our attention to it and
we will stay vigilant with that item. Next, we'll hear from
Mr. Yes, ma'am. Thank you. We will respond accordingly.
Our next speaker is Mr. Jason Oliver. Mr.
Oliver, if you're with us or hit
star six to unmute, I'm here. Good morning.
First, I want to speak up in support of Leanne
and the arts proposal. Like, there was
significant losses and hot taxes and using ARPA
funds for revenue replacement would be a great idea to kind of stimulate the
economy and economic activity in Houston.
First, and so along those lines, it's come up before, but I'm interested in
the process for approving ARPA fund suggestions. Can you share
that process and any rubric that exists? Also, I would like
to see the proposals that have been received by the mayor's office
thus far. And then second, HTV feels
like an under celebrated entity within the city, but it's vital for
transparency. As Ms. Hunter mentioned, the expenditures accepting
a two and a half million furniture and equipment line item seemed flat
decreasing over the past six years, even with the pandemic
going on. I'm wondering if HTV saw an increased workload during
the pandemic and if there was an increase in overtime or other pay, because I'm
not seeing it in the line items. Thank you. Thank you,
Mr. Oliver. I'm going to pick up on your final point there about the good
work of HTV. And I know council members have
been encouraged to utilize that facility and
that ability for us to really program according
to some of the highlights of what we're doing around City Hall.
So, again, thank you for your question, for being here with us virtually.
And Ms. Hunter, again, I want to thank you for your presentation today,
for your team being here with us in chambers.
And with that, we will take a break and
resume after lunch this afternoon at 01:00
with presentation of the budget workshop. Our next group to hear
from will be our legal department. And with that, our break commences.
Thank you, Chair. Thank you, Council.
Share the investment priorities identified by the Eastwood Civic Association.
We need relief on three lines to improve mobility in our community.
I will speak to the Galveston sub and my neighbor Lindsay, who's up next,
will speak about east and west belts later on the Galveston sub.
Our top priority is an underpass on lockwood, which was in the
presentation. This is the expected route of Metro BRT's
University corridor line. But let me be clear. Our neighborhood believes
an overpass in this area wouldn't be the right solution.
We are instead in favor of a small underpass that would provide the
community with one additional north south crossing, but still leave
seven crossings aggregate that are blocked daily. As such,
I urge the city of Houston to also seek funding for a rail improvement
study on this line to explore alternative solutions that address
the entirety of the sub, not just one crossing.
And this needs to be done in conjunction with Metro to ensure solutions
can be expedited to align with the timelines for BRT construction.
Thank you, Chair. My colleague Glimpsey will share priorities for East End,
West Belt or east and west belts in her remarks. Thank you.
Thank you very much, Ms. La Perrier,
and we'll proceed with the I believe hold on.
Before you leave the podium, we have a question from Chair Gallegos.
Thank you, Daniel, for being here today and representing Eastwood.
Just for your information, a couple of weeks ago, I did meet with
the new board chair, Sanjay, and did
bring that to his attention. He came into my office that there are concerns
in regards to the BRT going down lockwood, in regards to
an overpass that may be constructed or an underpass.
So they are aware of it and we are going
to be monitoring it. Thank you. Thank you, council member.
Proceed to our next speaker. Thanks again. Ms. Lindsay Williams
with us virtually and online. Proceed,
ms Williams.
If you'd hit star six to unmute,
we'll await your comment.
Ms. Lindsay Williams,
online.
We see you online. If you can unmute
star six,
we can come back to you if there are technical challenges.
With that nice intro from Danielle, I'm sorry we can't take
it right to Ms. Williams, but we'll come back to you if we can.
Mr. Tom Thompson, also online, virtually testing
our system here. Mr. Thompson, are you there? Are you able to mute unmute,
please. Unmute.
We see you, Mr. Thompson, and we know
we heard you at the public session this week at council.
We're checking our system to see if there's any technical challenges
right now, but proceeding with our list, a call
for either Ms. Williams or Mr. Thompson online.
And while we're addressing the challenges there, we will
proceed. Present here in chambers
is Punkaj Wadha.
Punkage is here with us. Let's hear from you at the podium,
sir. Thank you for being here. If you could state your name for the record
and proceed with your question or comment.
Yes, sir. Thank you.
Good morning. Good morning, Council. Good morning.
Thank you for holding this meeting. Thank you, BNSF,
for being present, providing vital
rail services to our city and the country. I just want to say I love
trains. I enjoy counting train cars with my kids
as they roll by when I'm stuck at one of the block crossings,
unfortunately. My name is Punkage Wadhwa.
I'm part of the Houston Quiet Zones Committee, and I'm one of the
residents in the neighborhoods that are near the BNSF
rail line that runs parallel to the 34th street tracks
just north outside of 610 Loop on the northwest
side from the neighborhoods from Oak Forest all the way to Independence
Heights. As you can see on the map I provided you guys,
there are over 500 households that have voiced their support
for the 34th Street Street quadzone corridor.
Considering each household typically has two to four residents,
there are at least several thousand Houstonians impacted
by the train horns on this stretch of tracks.
It's time to silence the train horns in Houston's. People in
countries around the world live in communities
that are much more dense without the obnoxiously loud
train horns. Houston can do the same. We don't
live in the 18 hundreds with coal fired trains belching
out black soot black soot and polluting the environment, do we?
Then why should we live with an outdated safety measure as a train horn?
The train horn is the last resort for emergency situations,
notifying anyone to get off the tracks,
same as it is for when we drive our vehicles. We don't honk our horn
every time we drive through an intersection.
We don't honk our horn when we change lanes. So we
have safety measures in place. And we have the technology to mandate,
per the City of Houston infrastructure Design manual, to put these
measures in place and have horns only as a last resort.
Per the FRA. The City of Houston has the authority
to mandate this, to put effective quiet zones in
place, as you guys have discussed earlier today, and I know you guys
are in process of doing that, but we need to do this now.
It's long awaited. You guys are part of the quality of
life committee. It's now time to make this better for all
citizens. Quality of. Life, especially the thousands of Houstonians
that have just advocated for this. If I
may have one more minute. Well, you can conclude your remarks.
Yeah, I have one more minute. I'll give you a few more seconds.
I'm speaking on behalf of thousands of members of we have
a long way to go today, Mr. Padwa. Thank you. Okay. Regarding funding and costs
of the quiet zones, I don't think the city should be burdened with this,
nor the taxpayers. Let's look at BNSF's
financial statement. In 2021, they had 22 billions in
revenue, 13 billions in expenses, with a net
income of 7 billion. Now, if you look at the number,
350,000 was mentioned earlier as a cost per.
If you'd like to intersection, we can take your comment online and we'll be
happy to post it and circulate it to the committees. But thank you
again for being here. I appreciate asking your question. I appreciate you allowing me
to speak. If you could wrap up, you're looking at 0.3% of BNF's
profits to implement a $2 million quiet zone along
the 34th street corridor.
Thank you very much. Appreciate that.
Proceeding now to our next speaker. We're going to try again for
online. Our speaker is Ms. Orlando Pulito.
Ms. Pulito, if you're here,
please join. There you are. Okay, thank you.
Ms. Pulito, we can hear you. Hello?
Go ahead, ma'am. We can hear you. Okay,
thank you for allowing me a few minutes to speak.
So I submitted in writing
my concerns to back up what I'm speaking of
today. So with the railroad I've been in this community for a very long time,
and I'm just very upset. The fact that
the railroad is sitting there talking about they have daily conversations,
monthly meetings, but yet there's no solution. In addition
to this blocking of
vehicles having to reroute include massive 18 wheelers
trying to get to these back industries, these are neighborhoods.
These are small streets. And these massive trucks navigating through the
community are not only tearing up our streets, but more importantly,
we have a trail, walking trail. We have a park,
but our wires sit low when they come through here, and I've
already reported this numerous times, they cause damage to my house in more ways
than one. They have popped my Internet wires,
causing my whole house to be damaged.
They forced their way in anyhow possible any way
possible. And I've submitted pictures of that. We have
children riding their bikes. We have people. We have older seniors
walking. These trucks are
trying to get to this industry. They're trying to exit this industry.
Our community streets are not for that. And the
young man before me was talking about the revenue. Yeah,
there has to be alternative ways in these meetings that they have to put this
revenue in effect. But more importantly
is, yeah, we need solutions and we need them quickly.
Thank you very much, Ms. Pulito. We do have the handout that you
brought or delivered to us with the photographs that you
mentioned. So thank you for that, and we
will post those and circulate. So thank you again for your
comments and being here. Seeing no questions from the council,
we're going to proceed to the next speaker, which is Ms.
Mara Gomez. Ms. Gomez is here with us in City
Hall chambers, so thank you for being here. If you join us at the podium,
we'd love to hear your comment or question today for the council.
If you could identify yourself. Yes, good morning.
My name is Mana Gomez, and I am with Link Houston, a nonprofit that
advocates for a robust and equitable transportation network so that all
people can reach opportunity. Today, I am addressing this joint committee about
the increasing burden train blockages continue to pose for transit
riders, bicyclists, and pedestrians in the
East End and Fifth Ward communities. Link Houston shares
many of the concerns residents are sharing with you today.
I live in the East End, so I experience firsthand the
impact these train blockages have on our communities.
We are forced to reroute to access jobs,
education, health care and wellness,
recreational opportunities, and other essential destinations.
For example, while riding Metro's 40 local bus route,
one day, the driver had to reroute along the I 45
frontage road and missed ten stops on both
sides of the train blockage. Several Metro bus routes
are often forced to redirect when trains block
a crossing, causing people to be late to their destinations.
Some pedestrians, school age children included,
go under or over in between the cars of trains
of stopped trains blocking their route and risk their lives by doing
so. Pedestrians will try to find the quickest way to their destination,
especially if they're being late affects their quality of
life. Additionally, they can force bicyclists
to reroute onto busier streets, which may not have
the built in infrastructure to afford sufficient safety.
So today, we ask the Federal Railroad Administration,
Up, BNSF and the KCS rail
companies to work with our local elected officials and communities to find
the best community driven solutions to these train blockages
with our most vulnerable road users in mind, and without further
dividing the communities the railway infrastructure goes through.
And we ask our elected officials to help hold these companies
accountable and do right by the communities they operate
in. Your efforts to remedy these issues will remove
adverse barriers and bring about equity in historically underserved
areas. Thank you. Thank you very much, Ms.
Gomez, for your comments. Seeing no questions in the queue,
we'll proceed. I see that Ms. Williams has
rejoined us or hopefully is able to unmute Ms.
Williams. Can you do that? There you are. Yes.
Can you hear me? Yes, go ahead. Loud and clear. Perfect.
My name is Lindsay Williams. I'm the Eastwood Civic Association train
committee chair, continuing to share our investment priorities. Danielle started
with on the west belt. We agreed with the prioritization of
York Street, presented by staff and included in the ten year old rail district
study. However, there is a critical missing piece in Phase one
needed to address the Nhhips plan. In anticipation of
the closure at Polk and St. Emmanuel, we would urge the inclusion
of an underpass at Leland as an equal priority. To allow Eastern residents
a straight access to downtown on the East Belt, the community desperately
needs at least one east west crossing, either at Polk lawndale or
telephone. Each crossing has its merits. Polk serves as a route
for Metro buses, lawndale would provide better access to Kip School and
post office, and the telephone may undergo a complete transformation if
the raised grant and Terra's 23 partnerships come through. There are
test choices, but we'd be happy to work with the city to engage with the
community on which crossing they would like to see prioritize.
Moving on from infrastructure to Quiet Zones since at least 2011,
the neighborhood has been seeking quiet zones across the West Belt, East Belt and the
Galveston Line. Each time, there's something preventing quiet zones from moving forward,
funding other priorities, or waiting on no horn signs.
Council, there are new Bil grants which could solve for funding.
We could have had quiet zones implemented a long time ago with the use of
grants to improve infrastructure, but it feels like our voices have gone unheard.
Money is available now, and there seems to be no urgency at the city to
apply for dollars to improve quality of life in the East End. Projects have
historically been focused on the West Side, and it's time to see dollars helping
those who live east of I 45 put the money where the problem is,
and it's in the East End. Chicago is already celebrating Bil
dollars that they expect to receive, and we are already behind.
So, passing it back to council, how soon do you expect to have the
first proposals ready for funding from the Bil? And I hope you
have an answer. Well, Ms. Williams, I want
to thank you for being here and asking your question. I don't see any council
members jumping at the opportunity to respond,
but at the same time, well, there we go. We've got Council
Member Chair Alcorn here to address you. Ms. Williams.
Thank you. Good question. And we'll find out.
And I just want to say I'm so impressed with the Eastwood residents.
I mean, you guys not only know your comments are with such specificity
that is so helpful about what you exactly want. You have a lot
of knowledge about the funding opportunities. You guys know
your stuff. And I for 01:00 a.m. Impressed by that and will certainly
do what I can to advocate for what you're talking about.
We are working very hard here. Thank you, Ms. Williams.
We have council member Gallegos also in the queue.
Thank you, Ms. Williams, for taking time to be here.
Just for your information, we have submitted a request to
congresswoman Garcia and congresswoman Sheila Jackson Lee
for funding for community project for the east
end quiet two zone. So we're hoping
that that will be approved. Thank you. Thank you council
member, and thank you Ms. Williams, for being here again for your leadership
in the community and bringing your question today. So with that,
we're moving on to the next speaker. We're going to try again for Mr.
Tom Thompson if he's back online and
able to join us, star six to unmute.
Otherwise, we're going to proceed with the
next speaker, which is Ms. Amy Din. Amy din
virtually with us, I believe. Amy,
are you there?
We're seeing you online but hearing nothing. Can you join
us with star six?
If not, we will proceed and hopefully get back from you.
The next speaker on the list is Mr. Clay Dippel.
Clay, glad you're with us. If you could approach to the podium,
happy to hear your question or comment today. If you could identify yourself for the
record. Thank you very much. I'm Clay Dippel, I'm also
a resident of Eastwood. I want to thank you committee members,
elected officials, chief pena, thank you. And to the railroads.
I also regret that the FRA could not make it. We have
established in several public meetings that the train blockages
in the east end have been increasing in frequency and in duration,
all while the trains themselves get longer,
while Houston's population grows. Union pacific tells us they
expect train traffic through our neighborhood is only going to increase with
just a $30 security camera at just one crossing
in Eastwood, private citizens have unmassed an incredible amount of
data to prove the scope of the blockage problem. It's measurable,
it's persistent, and it's about public safety.
The problem is only going to get worse. We come now to urge
the council to work with city public works starting today to use this
data and the data from these pilot surveillance programs to
create a concrete action plan. We want to know how Houston
can apply and allocate for infrastructure dollars for grade separated
underpasses completion of long promised quiet
zones and additional improvement studies so that a comprehensive plan
can give your constituents a clear understanding
of which projects you intend to apply for in each
year of the BIL's five available years.
Rail operators have long treated our neighborhood,
Eastwood like a parking lot for trains that are too long by their own standards
to fit in the switching yards built to accommodate them. They don't even know which
intersections they're blocking. The people who live and work
and shop and invest here want to see boots on the ground to secure
funding for a fix. Please take ownership of
this issue. Council members, you are our voice. We need you
to speak up for us. And I end with a question for council. What are
the city of Houston's funding request priorities for alleviating rail
blockage issues? And how do you intend to involve the community in
deciding which of these improvements come 1st? First of all, Mr.
Dibble, thank you very much for being here today. And for your question for
response is Chair Gallegos.
Thank you, Chair. And thank you, Clay, for your continued advocacy. I know you
and others were at the town hall held
by the Easton Chamber as well as the Fifth Ward and
there at Guadalupe Church with Congresswoman Sheila Jackson Lee.
And thank you for the nice handwritten note. Appreciate that
as well. Thank you. Also, I just want to say
that's why it's so important that Union Pacific and
Burlington Northern are aware of this
triangle wish affects Eastwood Fire Station
18. Again, it doesn't happen often, but it
does happen where there's a train on all three tracks.
So you're talking about residents, you're talking about emergency vehicles.
Again, you're talking about parents that can't take their kids to
school or pick them up after school. So it's just
chaos. And that's why I'm asking Burnington Northern and Union
Pacific to look at this triangle and ask your dispatchers
to not stop trains within this triangle because it impacts
quite a few residents. Thank you. Thank you, ma'am. Thank you,
Chair. Great question. Appreciate you being here. Our next speaker
is Ms. Erica Miranda, who I believe is online.
This is Amy Den. Okay. Can you hear me?
Yeah. Let's hold off on the question for Ms. Miranda and go back on our
list for Ms. Din. We can hear you, Amy. Go ahead.
Thank you. Sorry, somehow we had a
misconnection, so my name is Amy Denn. I'm the president
of Super Neighborhood 64 and 88. We appreciate your having
the second meeting on railroad operations after the January
2022 meeting. Since your first joint Committee meeting
in January, our Super Neighborhood conducted a community survey
regarding railroad impacts. And Mr. Hannigritt presented at our
February 9, 2022 Super Neighborhood meeting to
share the information with our community members specific to our neighborhood.
We also shared these results of that community survey with Mr. Hannigriff,
and we're happy to share that information with any of the council members that
are interested. We are glad that Council is continuing to engage
on this issue, the current railroad operations, our safety issues for
pedestrians, bicyclists, and vehicles in our Super Neighborhood and their
quality of life issues because of the horns, noise, and impact of productivity
for those traveling to work or school. Our survey revealed the following
concerns. First extended and repeated block crossings for
many hours at Lawndale and telephone by the Kip
post office at Leland and Scott at Lockwood
at Rusk and Harrisburg on Hughes Street at Polk
and Harrisburg on Griggs at Redwood and Bobby
Lee at the Gus Worthham Golf Course, blocking the pedestrian bike
and Bayou Trail to Capitol Street for hours on
Saturday morning. The Dumble and Harrisburg Intersections.
And at 1500 Telephone Road near Sierrajo We
also experienced regularly horn noise
during the day and night and specifically illegal
dumping along the rail line at 300 north
67th street in Houston, Texas.
77011 was reported. We thank you
for listening to our concerns and giving us this form. The results of our
survey are available by request. You can send the request
to me and I'm listed under Super Neighborhood Council information.
Thank you. Thank you, Ms. Stan. Appreciate your comments
and your ongoing work on the issue as well. All right,
we're now going to try for excuse me. Hold on,
Amy. Council Member Gallegos would like to address you.
Thank you, Amy. I just want to say thank you for being here again.
I know you addressed us in the January meeting that we had.
And thank you for representing the Eastwood
Lawndale Wayside super neighborhood again.
Twice in January and today. So thank you.
Thank you, Ms. Din. Our next speaker is Ms. Erica Miranda,
who is with us virtually. If you're online, speak up or
hit star six to Unmute.
Ms. Erica Miranda.
Okay, we'll put a hold on, Erica. If you join us,
please let us know or I'm here.
There you are. Okay, very good. Go ahead, Ms. Miranda.
Erica miranda. I'm an Eastwood resident.
I just wanted to say maybe the city
and the railroad can work on the low hanging
fruit, meaning the easy things. I would think
that it doesn't involve logistics because I work in logistics
and I know how hard that can be. But I'm thinking putting up
quiet stone signs does not inflict on logistics.
So that's something that can be worked on. Also putting
signs for alternate routes because there are bus drivers
that are new and they don't know the routes around the neighborhood,
it would be good for them along with bus drivers both
school and public.
Also, one of the roads that is used for
an alternate route coming off is Broadmore.
I know my mother lives between Broadmore and Munger and the
speed sometimes people are going 40, 50 and
maybe putting speed bumps or signs saying what the
speed limit is would be good. Also,
one of the roads that is used to do the
back way to get access to the access road and then get
into the neighborhood again is Knock Block Street. So that
street is very there's a lot of potholes.
It's very narrow and it does need to be fixed, I think for the
time being until data is put
together and a long term or midterm solution is done,
maybe something like this can be a short term solution.
And also on the long term to think whether it's an
overpass or an underpass, think of the people that
walk. I know my mom walks to the grocery store,
so sometimes she's stuck waiting for the train
to start moving and sometimes she's waiting two or 3 hours because of
the whole COVID thing. She was not taking public transportation,
but instead she was walking and so her trip to
the grocery store, even though it's a 45 minutes walk for her,
it would end up being a four hour transit
time because she needed to wait for the train. Thank you,
Miranda. Move on. Thank you. Ms. Miranda. Council member Gallegos
would like to respond. Thank you, chair.
Ms. Minonda, you had mentioned that you were hoping that we
could have some kind of signs or something to let people know that there's a
train, therefore they don't spend their time going to that crossing.
I know that the public works has reached out to my office
and they are working on some digital boards. I believe
there's one going up at Lawndale near Griggs. I believe there's one on
Wayside, and I'm not sure where the other 1 may go,
but hopefully in the near future, that will be tied into
the Smart railroad crossing. So that way it
lets the drivers know that there's a train, for example, at the 5200
block of Lawndale, and therefore the driver doesn't have to spend
their time going over there to find out there's a train blocking the
crossing. Thank you. Thanks again, Ms. Miranda,
for being with us. And thank you for your question. Next,
we'll hear from Mr. Brandon Martindale, who's with us
virtually.
Or are you here in person? Mr. Martindale,
we've got you as being with us present, but I do not see you
take a second to look for you again. No.
And we'll go on to the next speaker, Mr. Kyle Rogers,
online. Mr. Rogers, can you
speak up or hit star six to join us?
Hearing none, looking online.
We'll call you again, Mr. Kyle Rogers virtually with
us, otherwise proceeding next to Sarah Gutierrez.
Ms. Gutierrez with us online,
presumably, if you can hit star six
or speak up.
It's been a long meeting. Folks may be getting some lunch. Ms.
Gutierrez, last call for you.
Otherwise, we'll move on to
Ms. Virginia Ivanias. Ms. Ivanyez,
if you are with us virtually,
we'll take a moment to hear from you or hit star six if you can
unmute and we're not seeing you online.
Can you hear me? This is Kyle Rogers. I'm sorry,
go ahead. Kyle Rogers with us. Thank you, Kyle, for joining. We can hear
you. Why don't you go ahead? Okay, thank you.
Hello. At a recent three day NTSB national
Transportation Safety Board hearing on rail inefficiency,
a former BNSF supervisor stated that BNSF
utilizes public crossings as parking lots because its acceptable train
lengths exceed rail yard capacity.
Should public streets be used as de facto yards? I would
say no. But I want to know what does BNSF think?
What does up think? What does the FRA think?
What is an internally acceptable stoppage time for
a train to be blocking an upgrade track crossing?
Is it 30 minutes, 60 minutes?
120?
What are the reasons for the frequent blockages near BNSF
south yard, nearby telephone Lawndale and Polk to
up? What are the reasons for the frequent blockages at the
Galveston sub between Milby and Altic? Is it train length?
What investments or operational changes is BNSF
and up are making to reduce those blockages? We need
to know this. As of the last available data, trains are
stopping for over an hour on average, at the Galveston subline.
We want to work together with the city, federal regulators and railroads.
We have data. We can give you this data. But if you
would like something in return but we would like something in return.
We want minimal blockages. Children are frequently
tardied to school, affecting education. Goods are held up at these
blockages, affecting commerce. First responders are
rerouted during emergencies, affecting safety and health.
We urge our rail companies to keep better
blockage data and make it easier for the public to access. We urge
them to drastically improve their operations, especially in the East
End. We urge the federal representatives and regulators to look at how
railroads are operating and change the rules and laws to limit unnecessary,
unpredictable, and unprecedented blockages on our streets.
And lastly, we urge our city, county,
and state officials to help catalyze cooperation between us all.
To this end, we encourage any and all funding that will alleviate
our pain and be sought out and applications to be made.
Thank you. Thank you, Mr. Rogers. Great question, and I appreciate
your willingness to offer that data. We do have the
representative, Ms. Davis from BNSF, responding to your
question. Ms. Davis.
Sir, thank you very much for sharing.
Go ahead. Thank you, Mr. Chairman. Thank you very much
for sharing your concerns with us. We most certainly are
trying to move our trains as quickly and safely as we possibly can
through communities when there is an issue. As mentioned before, we try our best.
Our crews work to address those issues and
resume the movement of our trains. So we'll certainly take
your concerns back and talk to our operations team and also work with
Union Pacific to work on
that coordination and that handoff of our trains going in and out of our yard
as well. As I mentioned in my presentation before,
communication can always be improved. And so we are committed to both
communicating between our crews and our yard, as well as
between up dispatching and our crews. Thank you,
Ms. Davis. I want to thank you, Mr.
Rogers, again, for being here with your question. And I think
with that, we'll move on to the next speaker. And I'm told that Mr.
Tom Thompson is with us online. I'm going to try
that now. Mr. Thompson, can you unmute or identify
hello. There he is. All right, sir, go ahead with your question.
I'm sorry about the poor reception I have here.
No worries. Go ahead with your question or comment.
Sure. I just wanted to comment in
the presentation from Director Davis and Ms.
Summerlin, they pointed out some exciting new funding opportunities that
maybe could be applied for some of the issues we're talking about
here. Of course, it seems that all of them require some
kind of local match. And that's where it gets tough
for us because we have limited resources, as we all know.
But several years ago, the voters of Texas approved a
constitutional amendment that established
a Texas Rail Relocation and Improvement
Fund. This was back in 2005.
Unfortunately, that fund has never been funded by the legislature.
It seems to me that that could be a source of funding for the kind
of projects we're talking about here that could
be used for our match to get the federal funding.
And I'm a member of Texas Rail Advocates. This organization
is beginning a campaign now to solicit letters of
support that can be submitted to the Texas
State legislature prior to the 2023
session requesting them to actually allocate funding to the
Texas Rail Relocation and Improvement Fund. And I will
be following up with emails to the council members with
more information. Thank you. Thank you very
much, Mr. Thompson, for making it to us and for adding your
comment for the public record. Thanks very much. Thank you.
Proceeding with our next speaker, I'm going to call again briefly, virginia Yvonnez,
who I don't believe is with us.
And following that call is one now for
Batiri Bankston, who I believe is with us virtually.
Batiri Bankston,
we're looking for phone number and seeing none.
If you're there, hit star six or identify
otherwise. Moving on then to our next speaker is Mr.
James Ganarelli. Mr. Gonorelli virtually
with us. If you can speak up or
hit star six to unmute join
us with your who do we have?
This is James gunrelli. Okay. Go ahead, Mr.
Gunrelli. Go ahead. Thank you, chair. Thanks for allowing
me to speak today. I've lived here for
16 years in the same house in the Fifth Ward, and I've
experienced all the issues that everyone else has mentioned
from loud horns, lots of blockages, being stuck in a
triangle where if you've got one behind you and one in front of you,
you can't go anywhere. Hour, 30 minutes,
delays getting to work, trying to do things in the evening.
I'll submit the more details on these intersections
and also where 18 wheelers are rerouting due to blockages that
will shake my bed at 530 in the morning.
And I'll send those for comment. Kind of ad
living a little bit here because I learned a lot today listening to everybody
and I noticed two themes that I would hope could be addressed.
One of them is that the onus continues to be on the citizens
to report the blockages through a website, a phone number,
so many different ways or three step
process on UP's website. I really then with
Mr. Bounds in the pilot program noticed
that more passive gathering of the data continuously
real time is going to provide much more benefit.
So the second part of it is there seems to
be so much request for funding that
will have to be out there that either comes from federal tax dollars, property tax
dollars, local match, everything else. And I noticed with
all those partners that were listed,
we unfortunately didn't see Union Pacific
as one of them on there. So I would hope that they could
be a willing partner, especially with as cheap as he said so that we
can hopefully turn this from not just a pilot program,
but more into a much more continuous one and
to touch on what everyone else has said. I remember in 2007
when Mayor Bill White took a helicopter around and
spoke about the arrogance of the stops trains
that were around here. And since 2007,
Union Pacific has spent $48.2 billion
on stock buyback. Thank you very much Mr. Generally appreciate your
comment. Your time has expired. Appreciate that point.
And with up here still in
the chamber today, I think your point is a strong one
for how they might continue to step up or further
step up. So I appreciate that comment from you for the
record today. Thanks again for being here. And our next
speaker on our list will move now to Mr.
Oscar Aguilar, who I believe is
with us in the chamber. Yes, sir. If you would come forward to the podium
and state your name for the record,
we'd appreciate hearing from you,
Mr. Aguilar. Thank you,
Mr. Chairman. Yes, sir. Committee members, I'm Oscar Aguilar,
General Counsel for State Senator Carol Alvarado, and today I'm here on her behalf and
I will be reading a statement from her. Dear committee members,
as a native of the East End, I have witnessed firsthand the logical and quality
of life issues that have resulted from the Blocket crossings
in the East End. Rail traffic has long kept our communities isolated from
each other, and as important as rail traffic is, the ability of
our community to remain connected is much more paramount. My district
office is located at the intersection of Lockwood and Harrisburg alongside
a BC rail line in the East End. On a
weekly basis, trains luggagely move through the neighborhood, often stopping
and blocking multiple crossings along the track.
Consequently, many of my constituents daily routines are often thrown
off by the extensive weights and unnecessary detours that these
blockages cause. Moreover, first responders often drive
our office responding to calls for service, only to find block crossings
putting further distance between them and where they're needed. The train
disruptions largely affect the communities I represent, and I am glad to
see the city of Houston is working towards a solution. I appreciate the
initiative that the Houston City Council is taking to find solution to this ongoing
problem. The Smart Railroad Crossing Monitors pilot program includes several
BC crossings in my district, and I'm eager to review the data that
the program will produce. The federal funding solutions discussed today
are also a. Good step in the right direction. And I look forward
to your input on how state resources can be used to address the issue.
We must continue the discourse so that rail companies know that this is
an issue that can no longer be ignored and an issue that will
take significant action from their part to address. I look forward to
our continued work together to address the transportation and quality
of life needs of Houston and Senate District Six.
Sincerely, Carol Alvarado, state Senator for District Six. Thank you.
Thank you very much, Mr. Aguilar, and for the letter that is here
submitted for the record. Thank you to her and for her involvement as
a member of the Senate Transportation Committee. I know we're
very grateful for her service and for yours as well. Council Member Gallegos.
Thank you, Chair. Thank you, Mr. Aguilar. And also thank
Senator Alvarado for the letter and for her support
in our efforts to address this issue.
Thank you. Thank you. Council member. Thank you, Chairman. Yes, sir. And thanks
for getting that onto the record. Returning now for a moment to our speaker.
We understand Batiri Bankson is with
us online. Ms. Bankson,
Batiri Bankston told
that you're with us online. If not, we will proceed.
Hit star Six or let us know you're there.
Otherwise we'll move on in the chamber. I believe with us
is Mr. Tony Garcia. Mr.
Garcia is here with us. If you'll come forward and
identify yourself, we'd love to hear your comment or question for the
committees assembled today. Thank you, Mr.
Garcia. Thank you, Chair Robinson. Thank you,
Chair Gagos. So for those of you that don't know me,
I'm Tony Garcia. I'm a local East End resident. I'm a businessman,
community leader, philanthropist, and all around just community servant.
As I was here in this meeting today, I was just blown away by the
things that I've been hearing. And I just want to give you my point
of view. From my perspective, the number ten comes to mind,
and that is my everyday task. It's ten. It's ten railroad
crossings that are blocked while I'm trying to access my child,
to get them to school, to see my mother, who is a grandmother
and an elderly woman, reporting to my office,
reporting to several of my businesses and reporting to my cafe.
Ten crossings every day that are blocked in
the East End. Resident that's Lawndale. Leland Lockwood.
Milby Oakhurst. Polk. Scott samson,
Ernestine. And if I missed a few, my apologies.
This just has to stop. I do business elsewhere in
Houston and throughout Texas. And I can share with you that I don't encounter
ten blockings anywhere in Houston other than the East End. So at
what point did our lives become less valuable?
At what point did the city say it's okay for up and BNSF
to just park your trains on our tracks? This must stop now.
I heard earlier about detections and cameras and
quiet zones and how they know how they can detect when they're
approaching a quiet zone. Well, clearly an engineer is certain
he's blocking a track. They know what they're doing.
And I can't imagine that it's anything from mechanical failure
when it happens on a routine basis. Every single day
they deliberately block our tracks.
It's hindering our quality of life. It's a safety hazard.
It's as if every single day we parked a train
outside your home, BNSF and up, and said, you can't get out,
you can't go to the hospital, you can't take your child to school. We're just
going to park a track outside your house.
That's all I have. My name is Tony Garcia, and I thank
you for the time. Well, thank you, Mr. Garcia, for paying attention and for being
with us. Council Member Gallegos would like to address you. Thank you, Chair.
And thank you, Tony, for your time, for being here. I know you're a busy
man, and I know you are very active in the East End, so thank you
for everything you do for our communities in the East
End. And like you stated, Leland, I know
you have one of your offices there on Leland, just a block or so away
from the railroad track. So I can only imagine the frustration
that you and your employees go through not
able to get across that railroad track.
So, again, thank you for everything that you do. Thank you. Mr.
Garcia, if you would entertain one comment from
Chair. I know Council Member Gallegos and I were recently at
the botanical Garden, or right adjacent to it for a track completion
for part of our pedestrian and rail. And I rode my bike back
from there and was through your neighborhood and witnessed myself a
number of blocked intersections. And I know from
my route that I've got an app on my phone where I know exactly where
I went on that bike ride that day. And with your ten crossings,
I wonder if you know such an app that you could map your daily route.
Because what you just described to me is not only compromise
of your personal quality of life, but one that also is
representing what we're here fundamentally for today, which is public safety
and the concerns that, among others, chief Pena described. So I
would love to see what you described mapped. And if you need any help,
let me know and I'll loan you mine. I appreciate that,
and I will be certain to map it out for you and convey it to
your office. Okay? Thank you for your time. Thank you, Mr. Ricarcia. Thank you,
Council. Okay, our next speaker is with us online
and virtually. I believe that's Mr. Andrew Wright, if you're
with us, hit star six or speak
up and we can hear you now.
Mr. Andrew Wright, are you still with us?
Okay, we're hearing from Ms. Virginia Ivanyez,
who we think is online. If you're able to speak.
We'd love to hear from you. Ms. Ivanyez hit
star six to unmute.
Not hearing you. We're going to move on. I do see Mr.
Mark Klein with us in chambers. So let's move to your comment.
Mr. Klein, I believe you're on the north
side. I am, thank you.
If you could. Chair Althorn and Chair Geigos and
Chair Robinson. I appreciate it. I'm Mark Klein, president of Super Neighborhood Twelve,
and I've been working on the 34th street quiet zone since 2010.
And we've worked really long and hard.
Thousands of residents support it. It was a crushing blow when, in 2011,
the funding mechanism, which was rebuilt, Houston passed, and so the funding
mechanism for quiet zones went away. And so we spent
the next seven years, or at least I did, talking with Public Works jeffrey Weatherford,
harry Hayes, ellen Cohen, formerly City Council,
District C, and others. And we're told that there just wasn't
any money and that we'd have to find skin in the game to
get the city council to pony up its share. And I understand that.
But the amount of money we were talking about at the time, half million dollars,
that would be a momentous undertaking for any nonprofit to
take, let alone a bunch of volunteers. And so we were 9th
on the list when that list, eight of us, got completed. So when that list
went away, this is a list that had been vetted by council, by staff,
and then all of a sudden, we are facing that this has been reshuffled.
And now 34th street quiet zone could be anywhere on the list. And I just
want to make sure that it remains top of mind for
you folks and City Council, we're talking about the largest quiet zone
that would occur in Houston. It would impact thousands
of residents. It would improve the safety for their elementary schools,
high three high schools, the YMCAs on it.
There are affordable housing, apartment complexes on it.
And most importantly, there's an underserved community that has probably been
underserved since it was formed in 1915. And that's Independence Heights.
And this could be a huge improvement for them. And they just built
that new high school, burke or two. Washington. It's an amazing thing,
and I want to say that I'm always confounded by Burlington
Northern that doesn't necessarily pay or contribute
for some of these improvements. No one's asking anybody to pay the
full amount of this, but they did make $7 billion in profits
last year. And though some of those profits are born on the backs of residents
living along these lines that suffer from the consequences of noise pollution,
which research has shown to be as egregious as air pollution,
but none of those costs are baked into those profits.
And so this is an opportunity for a brand to really get out ahead of
itself and to not only help its shareholders, but to help stakeholders
in the community improve their lives, improve their quality of life. I've seen firsthand
what noise pollution and the train horn can do. And so this is a
great opportunity for BNSF to improve life for thousands of Houstonians
and for city council as well. Thank you, Mr. Klein. Thank you very much
for being with us and your appeal to the industry. We appreciate
that very much. A few more speakers on our list.
We will proceed with virtually with Ms.
Ruby Thomas. Ms. Thomas, if you're with us at star six
or start talking, ms.
Thomas, Ruby Thomas looking for you online,
star six. Otherwise we will move on.
Our next speaker is Ms. Paulette Kukuk
in the chamber today. Ms. Kukuk, glad you're with
us. If you could take the podium and
state your name for the record. Congratulations for saying
my name correctly. Well, it's very difficult.
Hello, I'm Paulette Kakuk. I am a director with the
Eastwood Civic Association, and I would like to share some
information in regard to the intersections blocked on the Galveston
sub as a result of stop trains.
This data was collected by a surveillance camera directed at
the crossing at Eastwood dot number 85
95 22 y. In March
of 2021, 218 trains
traveled this crossing, of which 26 stopped
and blocked the intersection for a total of 20 hours.
In March of 2022, we saw 188
trains travel this crossing, of which 63
stopped and blocked the intersection for a total of 73
hours of blockages. That's 30 less
trains, but 37 more blockages and
52 more hours in a year to year comparison.
This illustrates that this problem is getting much worse.
Despite fewer trains traveling the track for the
last six months. I've painstakingly recorded the
details of every train that's traveled this crossing. Here's what
we learned. We see an average of 163
trains a month. Of those,
34% of them come to a complete stop and block
the road for at least ten minutes. The average duration
of the blockage is 62 minutes.
Each month, this crossing is blocked for a total of 56
hours. On average, the longest single blockage
was 8 hours and 38 minutes. We see
at least one blockage of over 3 hours every month.
This is just a snapshot of what it looks like in the East End.
This is a single crossing on a single rail line.
The impacts are similar at other crossings on
other lines. We need the city to accelerate and expand
its smart railroad crossing. Monitor pilot.
I would like to ask council and staff,
are there plans to regularly share the data from the
pilot publicly? Thank you very much for your time.
Well, thank you very much, Ms. Kokokin. I think the intention is very
much to share that data. How we do that?
I think we're taking a good look at it with the partners
who've presented today. And I do see Mr.
Hannigraff behind you, who presented earlier, who may like to approach.
Can you please come forward, mr. Hannigraff, if you'd like to be on
the record with your comment or response? No, I've been working really
closely with the East End community and they have been providing us the data
to help us compile the entire story along with
our sensors. Excellent. And we know the concentration of railroad
crossings in the East End, the triangle that Council
Member Gallegos has been speaking of today. So we're grateful
for your data collection, your observations, and for working with our team.
Thank you very much. Thank you. We do. Miss Kakuk, if you'd
hold on, council Member Gallegos would like to speak.
Go ahead, sir. Thank you. Thank you, chair paulette,
if there was an East End award, you'd be the recipient of the East
End award for 2022. Can you please share how you
gathered all this information? Yes, I'd be glad to. I bought
a Wise camera for $30. I mounted
it at the back of the house because the train track is right behind our
house. And each day I look at
the data that's collected from the camera and it
records for 24 hours. I painstakingly look at each
time there is a stop train and how long it stopped.
I record it and I give it to Danielle,
who converts it into a chart. Wow.
So thank you. Thank you for taking your personal
time to do this for our community. Thank you. Glad to. Thank you.
Thanks. Ms. Cook and I had a Lionel train when I was a
kid. I want your help building that next train set.
You all are awesome. We may be down to our final speaker on
the list before we call anyone who we've missed.
Ms. Melissa Bealer, I believe you're with us virtually.
Ms. Bealer, if you could hit star six or unmute going
once, going twice, and ask again for Ms.
Bealer to unmute or speak
now and hearing nothing there, I'm going to call any of those who
may have missed. And thank you,
Chief. My chief of staff has
done an incredible job. I want to thank Diana Caisedo,
as well as Daniel from Council Member Gallegas's
office, as well as Jordan from Council Member Alcorn's office, and the
rest of our staff. You all are doing great work for us. Thank you
so much. And we have been passed to two speakers who are with
us in Chambers late editions. But we do want to hear from
everyone. Mr. John Segovia. Mr. Segovia, if you're with us,
please state your name for the record.
And thank you for being here. Good morning,
Council. If it's still morning. It's not, but good
afternoon. My name is John Paul Segovia.
I open up an hello? If you could hold on speaker,
we'll take one more call in a moment, but Mr. Segovia,
go ahead. Thank you. My name is John Paul Segovia.
I opened up an art gallery in the East End about three
years ago and it sits in between five train tracks
on Samson and Rusk. So being
there every day for the last three years, I get to witness this
firsthand every day. So it's hard for my clients
to get to appointments because of daily train blockage. The biggest
thing here is the train horn abuse. Train conductors
will blare their horn for minutes at a time and it's very
annoying if you're trying to host an event there.
You get trains on both sides coming in and it's just a constant blare.
If there's trains parked on the track, then future trains
will come through there and still continue to blare their horn. So it's
like, who are they warning at that point if there's already trains blocking
that area? So when can we
expect the quiet zones to take place?
Right? I hear everybody talking about this,
but really, how hard is it to implement this? Why is there
talk about all this budget and cost and cost effectiveness
and all this? A human knows how to blow
a horn, why is there money behind it? Right? So just educate them.
I've taken pics and videos of being blocked completely on both sides
and there is a housing development next door that is the
Samsung Lofts. And so if I'm blocked in as a business and they're
blocked in at their homes if anything
were to happen, I know there's a chemical company that works next
door. If that something were to happen, catch on fire, we have no place to
go. And listening to the Fire in Chief expresses
the concerns of being alert of train blockage made me
realize this Uber technology has been around for twelve
years now, and I work for a logistics company who has adopted
this technology back in 2015 to monitor the driving routes
of their trash trucks. Why is it taking the Railroad
Commission so long to implement this technology? And you
spoke about an app that you have on your phone and you're going to pass
that information to my friend Tony Garcia. And why isn't the Royal
Commission adopting this technology? Alerting the Fire Chief
of train blockage. Thank you Mr. Segovia. And you have been
joined at the podium from Ms. Davis, from the city. Ms. Davis,
if you'd like to respond.
Okay, so as far as quiet zones go,
as the previous speaker mentioned,
priorities change and this is prior to me taking this role. And so
we have added more signature programs like the Mayor Street
Rehab Initiative to which we aim to
redo 2% of our roads every year. We work very closely with
the council members, the district council members on that.
So since coming into this role, we have been moving some funding
to the quiet zones. But there's a two part effort. So there's the part
on the city where we have the five that we have right now that
are pending, where we're doing our portion of that,
whether it's upgrading the pavement
markings or the channelization for the cars.
So that is something that we do on our side. But it is an
effort when we do the quiet zones, because there are times when
there are things that need to happen on the rail side, and we can't compel
them to do it, but we do partner with them on quiet zones. And so
that's just generally what can take so long. And so I do have a staff
person. Part of their role is quiet zones and part is school
zones, but we are moving forward with the ones that are pending.
Thank you for that discussion and explanation. We appreciate that.
And without any comments or council members in
the queue, we want to thank you for being here today. I didn't see that.
Council Member Gallegos. Go ahead. Thank you, Chair. Thank you for
being here today. I know you were asking about quiet zones there around Samson
and York. Again, that's where we've submitted
to Congresswoman Garcia and Congresswoman Sheila Jackson
Lee for community project funding for
that area right in there for a quiet zone.
And it's estimated that it will cost about $3.6 million
to convert those crossings right in there into a quiet
zone. So I can only ask that you and your neighbors
and businesses in the area please contact Congresswoman Sylvia Garcia,
congresswoman Sheila Jackson Lee, and let them know that the city
of Houston has asked for them to secure some funding
from community project funding, these $3.6 million
so we can address that. Great. Thank you. Yeah. And then I will
add that's the one of ours that's a priority for grade separation. And so we
have that. We're at about 30% design. And so those are ones that
when the notice of funding becomes available, again, depending on the criteria,
that is one at the top of our list to submit to get the funding
so that we can close the gap. And the Chair will note
also that with our partnering with our federal friends,
the aforementioned Congress folks, Sheila Jackson Lee and Sylvia
Garcia, with the new return of potential earmarks
and funding, some things
have changed with the IIja, and we will continue to pursue
every opportunity to work with those available funds.
So thank you again, both, and Council member for your response.
We're going to turn to our final signed up speaker,
Mr. Juan Paras.
Did I hear from here he is. Mr. Paras, thank you for being here.
Coming to the podium, if you identify yourself
for the record. Yes, sir. Thank you. My name is Juan Paras,
and I live in the East End.
Pardon me. Go ahead. Okay. And I
live almost at the corner of Lockwood and Harrisburg and
Rusk runs parallel to the Harrisburg rail line.
And I've heard a lot of good issues raised,
but nobody's raised the issue of why
don't the railway arts just expand their railway
yards facility so the trains can have a place to park?
Because they're so often blocking our communities that I consider
that their parking lot, their unofficial parking lot.
And if they have to pay for parking there,
I think we would generate a lot of money for the city.
So that's just another idea. But needless to
say, this is also an environmental justice issue.
The East End is inundated with environmental justice
issues, train traffic, 18 wheelers
running on our streets, and numerous
issues that impact our communities and standard of living.
So I would propose that one of the ideas is to
expand the rail yards or to penalize or give
fines. Like when you're parking at a meter and it expires, you get a penalty,
right? You pay a fine. If we had something like that,
it may encourage the railroad industry
to expand their rail yards and
accommodate the traffic that's coming into Houston.
Thank you, Mr. Paris. Thank you. Sounds so sensible and easy.
I don't know if our chair of the regulatory affairs, who handles
all parking issues in the ordinance, if you want to think about a levy
for the train companies. Do we have any interest in responding from BNSF
or up? Ms. Davis or
please come forward, sir. Thank you for your question.
Again, for the record, if you could identify yourselves.
Thank you, Mr. Chairman. This is Tessa Minor from BNSF.
I just wanted to respond to I'm sorry, I missed
his name. Just wanted to respond, Mr. Paris, mr. Paras,
I appreciate that. Unfortunately, the railroads were built hundreds
of years ago, and Houston is built at city around the railroads.
And so that limits our capacity to expand our yards.
Okay, there's one answer. How about you, Mr. ZenTek?
So, I would say the capacity projects that I was talking about going on
at Inglewood, we are looking at what improvements
can be made, some of which we had talked about earlier, between the signal upgrades
as well as within the yard itself. So there are those projects
that we're looking at continuing to make a number of various investments
within the state of Texas related to our siding projects to
be able to accommodate the growth.
For the record, are you two and your companies both officially against a
parking fee?
I believe the fifth no. Yes, I'm against
it. Jokes aside, appreciate creative solutions, and we are
looking for ways in which to address these concerns. So thank
you all again for being here. Thank you, Mr. Chairman. Thank you.
Yes, we're now at the end of our list.
We have now a point where we'd like to make a last call for
those speakers who have not.
Hello? Can you hear me? We are calling for one last round.
Yes, who's on the line, please? Hi,
this is Melissa Bealer from Air Alliance, Houston.
Say your name, please, one more time.
Melissa Bealer. Melissa Bealer.
Very good. Go ahead with your comment or your question.
Thank you. Good afternoon, council members. Again, my name is Melissa
and I'm with the transportation justice coordinator for
air Alliance Houston, who envisions healthy communities
with clean air every day for everyone.
I don't want to take up too much time. I just want to say that
we are in support of our neighbors and our community partners
in requesting improved conditions to rail operations in
Houston. We understand and also express
the same frustrations that the community does in
terms of the fact that while we are looking at solutions
today with railroad companies, it's been a long time coming.
And communities, these are the communities that often
get the harms as opposed to the benefits of
our transportation system. And there's definitely some
cumulative impact issues compounding with pollution
from the port and the highways. Communities are concerned
about train pollution while idling as well. So that
might be something that industry could speak to a
bit in terms of whether or not the best
available technology to reduce or eliminate emissions while
Idling and while we deal with these train blockages are in fact happening
for Houston. I also wanted to mention my own experiences
with train blockages, having visited Magnolia
Park when I was working with community members to learn
more about the improvements that they'd like to see for the braze bayou trail.
We tried to go visit a trailhead, the best trailhead
that they can visit at capitol street,
right behind the multi service center there.
And a train was blocking the trailhead, so we had to go walk
to wayside where it has very narrow
sidewalk. It's honestly gravel in
some places and not a sidewalk. And we're facing three lanes
of oncoming car traffic. Thank you. Trying to go in like a
single mile line. Thank you, Ms. Bealer, for your comments today
and for joining us online. Thank you very much.
I think Ms. Ruby Thomas may be online. We're looking again
for Ms. Thomas. Ruby, are you there?
If so, speak up or hit star six.
I think we're having challenges with getting you online. We're going to
call one last time for Ms. Virginia Ivanyez.
Understanding you may have joined us back online.
Understand, Ms. Thomas, you may be trying to unmute
hit star six on your phone. Speak up.
We'd love to hear from you. And if we can't hear from you, you can
always submit your question to any of the chairs who are co
sponsoring this meeting. That's council Member Sally Alcorn,
council Member Robert Gallegos or myself, council Member David Robinson.
So with that,
I'm going to call for any final speakers.
Last time for any speakers to hit SAR
six or speak
up. I think we have come to the end of our time. Council members,
I'd like to thank you for being here, your staff and all members of the
public, both online virtually as well as in the chamber.
For final comments, let me call first on council member Robert Gallegos.
Thank you, chair. I was in the queue. I just wanted to thank
Mr. Padas for your years of advocacy
in our community addressing environmental issues. So thank
you for everything that you do in the community.
Let me again thank all the public speakers who testified today and
shared the very serious issues they're seeing and filling
in our community due to poor rail operations.
As I told up back in January, and I say to be an SF
today, it is of utmost importance that the railroads
work collaboratively with cities and communities to identify
and implement mutual beneficial
solutions. We can no longer accept prolonged
blockages lasting four and 8 hours
and even 14 hours. As it was learned today,
blocking major thoroughfares and neighborhood streets leaves
residents stranded, frustrated, and first
responders must scramble to find alternate, longer routes.
And as we all know, every second counts
in emergency responses.
Prolonged blockages are unacceptable and must
be corrected. I ask the railroads to please work with
us, to remain engaged and operate more
responsibly. Finally, let me thank
Director Jesse Bounds, jack Hanigriff,
and all the partners recognized earlier for
all they've done to get us to this point and for working with my
office to bring this pilot to fruition. I really
do appreciate their work and dedication. The findings they
previewed with us today support citizen observations
and complaints about blocked city streets and
critical crossings. And as we noted,
the data gathered through this pilot will be utilized
to better understand, manage and control the impacts
of block crossings and to inform and
encourage data driven collaboration between communities,
federal regulators, and the railroad companies.
Again, thank you all and let's all continue to
work together. Thank you. Thank you. Council Member. Council Member alcorn.
Thank you, Chair. And thank you, Council Member Gallegos. I certainly can improve on that.
What I do want to say, what I heard from residents today was about
a comprehensive plan, some kind of knowledge of
when your grade crossing or your quiet zone might be
in the queue. So I want to talk more with public Works about
a comprehensive plan to address these, especially with all these
infrastructure dollars available. Thank you to the railroads for
coming. We need you. Our city economy, state and national economy
need the trains. We all just have to figure out how we can better get
along and be better neighbors. Thank you. Thank you,
council member. And again, thank you to all of our participants today, those who've
presented staff and council for their support and attendance
today, I want to remind the public and urge the
community to continue reporting instances of blocked crossings to
www dot FRA dot
gov blockedcrossings,
and to call Union Pacific at 188-87-7267.
Want to thank again council members Robert Gallegos and Council Member Sally Alcorn
and their teams for participating with us. All of these presentations
will be compiled and placed online for
the public to see in future reference. And with that, I want to thank everyone
again and. We are adjourned.